so but one of these images that people
have when they think of Oxford Cambridge
they have guys dressed in black tie the
ladies dress their elegant ball gowns a
nice sophisticated evening of fine
wining and dining and most of that's
true a bull to us is basically a massive
special party it's not the kind of thing
which happens every week a bull is the
kind of thing that you go to one or
maybe two of in a year and you just
haven't fantastic even the way that they
were if is ever so slightly between
Oxford Cambridge in Oxford Bulls tend to
happen in the first half of the last
term of the Trinity term before
everybody's exams in Cambridge on the
other hand everybody waits until after
all the exams are finished and they have
their Bulls in maybe and bulls can be
either black tie or white tie a black
tie ball is the normal ball and it's the
image that only has in their minds well
a white tie ball is generally more
expensive they tend to happen at
commemoration Bulls which are rare
events and instead of wearing a black
tile you wear a white bow tie and a
tuxedo so tails but the way that these
Bulls work across the board is that you
pay a set ticket price and that can
range from 50 pounds to 250 pounds and
once you have paid that that's it once
you get inside the ball everything is
free so you have unlimited access to
drinks food entertainment music you name
it and balls are organized via college
so most colleges in the university would
put me on a ball either yearly or every
other year and they're organized by a
elected committee of students that
committee is in charge of everything
from booking
entertainment music food drinks sourcing
out the the deccan of mission for the
venue's but balancing the budget quite
an important thing and also deciding on
the theme so whilst this college Bulls
theme was the Roaring Twenties in the
past we've had french revolution themed
we actually had a monopoly themed one in
which the front quad was turned into a
Monopoly board I've been to before where
it was four seasons and this college
which had four quads was converted into
having spring summer autumn and winter
I'm going to try to describe to you guys
what a bull is basically like via an
example which was my colleges
which was because 2013 presents the
Roaring Twenties now this was a
fantastic night I think it was probably
the best night of my life not least
because my best friend from home John
was coming up and visiting me in Oxford
and he hadn't been to evolve all so
everybody queues up outside and you have
outside the college that's massive long
queue of people in black tying to ball
gowns and after a we we then went in and
there was a champagne reception on the
front quad of my college we had dancers
doing a performance on the front quad of
the college which was sort of slightly
surreal and everybody sort of Mills
around was very sophisticated and you
pick up one of these program for the
night so this is a map of the college
displaying where like the food and drink
is available but also on the back you've
got a set list for the different venues
so then perhaps the college have been
turned into like food and drink courts
while other parts of the college have
been turned into performing venues there
was a massive marquee on one of the
quads which I had music throughout the
night and the night I should point out
ranges from 8 o'clock till 4 o'clock and
the music they had on was fantastic they
had a live jazz band they had the
college's fantastic Scarborough
marvellous medicine doing an hour-long
set DJ sets then at the end of the night
we had a silent disco in there well in
the JCR they were offering dance lessons
for 1920s classic dances like Charleston
and then after that they did basically
DJ sets and in one of the side rooms of
the college we also had a jazz band who
were doing just jazz classics and it was
a model of like a 20s speakeasy which is
really really cool to have these like
round tables and people were just moving
in and out and shedding for a little bit
and listening to the music was really
classy however the first thing it was on
my mind when I got into the ball was
food because I'm absolutely starving and
bulls tend to have at least a good
couple of food outlets in this case we
had Jean Dee's ice cream we had a candy
floss vendor we had some like a noodle
store we had a burrito store it had
pulled pork burgers so you've got your
music you've got your food then of
course you need your drink and across
the college there were loads of bars
obviously the college bar was open that
was really refreshing towards a walk in
and just like
Haven just pick up a pint and not pay
for it and then other larger rooms in
the college were also converted into
you cocktail bars and just like normal
bars so you put your music your food
needing to go he already have a
fantastic night and a lot of the night
is spent just in black tighten both
counts dancing and having a like
fantastic time but there's also some
extra entertainment stuff they put in
there so one of the big rooms in college
was converted into a casino and you just
picked up shifts in the way and sat down
in your black tie felt like James Bond
and you could play roulette or poker
that's actually quite a bit of poker
that's a dangerous thing to discover
they also had installed Swing boats like
Victorian swim boats on one of the quads
which mean my mate John went on for
quite some time and that was fun John
all night pulling machines but I think
the highlight of the whole night was I
think about two o'clock in the morning
when me and a bunch of friends and John
and a bunch of guys who I knew in the
year above me but left the college rule
dancing on the front cot and they'd
install these massive speakers in a
college library like blaring up Beyonce
and we were all dressed up like really
nicely just getting it done and it was
so weird but so fun to be dancing on
this symbol of Oxford this like green
grass quad with everything else right
you know you're in black time you're at
a ball but you're dancing to Beyonce and
you're tensing on the quad not next to
it it felt really strange but somehow
really right and most importantly it
felt really fun it was like I say the
best night I think I've ever had I'm
incredibly proud than my college and the
ball committee put on such a fantastic
show I mean our college ball doesn't
happen every year happens every other
year so I know that in two years time
they've got a lot to learn